okay I guess we're live
good morning or hello depending on your
time zone I'm continuing on my 90 date
challenge in Arabic and farsi and so
every day as I do my different learning
activities I I think about what I'm
doing and different aspects of what I'm
doing which I want to share with you and
so what I have been doing recently in my
Arabic and again basically till about
noon today is Arabic and then I switched
to Farsi so I'm half my week is Arabic
half my weakest Farsi and I explained
last time that I'm sort of in this stage
now where I kind of more or less
comfortable doing easy content I really
struggled to do difficult content so I
kind of go back and forth I think you
know I there was recently a blog post
that went on my blog or I talked about
you know in an ideal world you're always
progressing from content that's just a
little bit too difficult for you but in
fact it's very difficult or it's not
very practical to expect that you can
always find content that is both
interesting in just that little next bit
you know the next level of difficulty
for you and besides which as in the
title today you know language learning
is a fuzzy process I don't really
understand the concept of fuzzy law
logic in computing but it's it's sort of
it involves the idea that not everything
is a matter of true or false
right or wrong in traditional language
learning you know it's right or wrong we
have a task we get eight out of ten or
we get six out of ten in fact those
things that we got right on the test
we might get wrong the next time words
that we remembered for the test we may
forget the next time you know things
that we got wrong with might get right
the next time the same is true and we
speak we make mistakes that we may not
make the next time it's it's not a
logical progression step by step so you
know even I was saying
two of the books that I have bought to
help me in Arabic so I see mill I paid
someone to transcribe it and put it on
link I bought this thing is a very cheap
ones like ten dollars hair it's not
Montreal at the bookstore and it's you
know MIT though the Express it's not bad
and I also bought this other one Mandel
de la Modell all three of them I paid
someone in Jordan to transcribe so that
I can upload them in too late because
it's extremely difficult at least the
beginning to read in Arabic this way I
can look upwards as I go I can hear the
text-to-speech however bad the text
speech is it doesn't matter because I
then hear the the native voice and I get
a good sense of how the word is
pronounced but all of these they sort of
say you know here as Emil says if you do
all the 77 lessons you'll be b2 or
something and and the idea is that as
you progress through the book you are
you know firmly acquiring all this
knowledge of the language which isn't
the case I find that if I go back to the
early lessons I've forgotten a lot of
the stuff that was there it's it's not a
matter of sort of building blocks it's a
matter of gradual exposure and therefore
I find myself always going back to the
lessons that I did before and kind of
roaming around and the more difficult
stuff roaming back and do easier stuff
so that this is sort of a gradual
process of my osmosis we're never quite
sure what we retain so that makes the
whole process to me fuzzy I should also
point out that if since I've had some
books here I also grabbed you know I
find that any language verbs are key so
if I can get a simple book that focuses
in on the most common verbs I feel if I
can get a handle on the most common
birds I got the same in Farsi and
Persian as I'm gonna call them not
verbs are kind of key that's why our
mini stories are built around the most
common verbs in the language you can get
a sense of how the verbs work in
different situations normally that gives
you a bit of a core from which you can
build the language no today I'm gonna
demonstrate what I do on the iPad I have
hooked up my iPad
and it's a bit strange because I'm
talking here through the computers I
have my computer in front of me yet I'm
gonna be doing this on the iPad and I
think I'll be tempted at times to poke
my computer screen with my stylus or to
try and activate what's on the iPad via
the computer because it's a kind of a
little bit fuzzy all right so I'm going
to share my screen and you'll see that
it's my iPad screen and we will see how
this all works out and again if you have
questions don't you know don't hesitate
please provide your questions
they are relayed to me and and then I
hopefully will have be able to excellent
so if all is going well you should be
able to see my iPad screen and I will
quit out of this lesson and presumably
that's working I'll go straight out of
here so let's go alright let's go to the
library this is how it looks on the iPad
I hope you can see it I am in foreign
Persia or at least in Arabic I can
switch to other languages up here you
know choose any number of languages that
we have you'll notice that we have
Bulgarian and Gujarati
these typically are in the list these
are in order of when I last looked at
these languages so I had a peek at
Bulgarian and Gujarati Bulgarian looks
very similar very easy to understand
based on the other Slavic languages that
I have learned but we're not gonna go
there we're gonna stay with Arabic and
we are going to go to basically where I
was so let's go there this is the lesson
and so this is the final I decided again
because it's fuzzy I said okay I'm
struggling with content and something so
difficult was not as easy choice and
then a lot of the content in these books
like the SML and others it's short
they're short sometimes silly in the
case of ischemia
disconnected short little bits of
content not doesn't really engage you
the higher ups is more sort of at the at
the train station at the post office at
the Museum that kind of thing so they're
all snippets of content not really
connected anything so I said okay what I
will do I will go into the last lesson
in s email and work my way back and
because again sort of fuzzy logic it
doesn't really matter it's not like
you're learning and you have to do less
than 1 and then lesson 2 and less than 3
in lesson 4 at the beginning you do and
maybe I should point something out here
so with every lesson you have this this
is an important the lesson info and the
same exists on the computer it gives you
some information about the lesson so
there's a hundred and 60 words in total
in this lesson there's 139 unique words
every time I read it I sure and I have
tended not to do so but I'm going to do
so in the future I should give myself
credit for having read in a second time
and the third time similarly with
listening if I'm not listening if it's
if I listen to it in the playlist or
here it will it will
you know register but I guess if I'm
listening in in some other way which is
not being recorded I should update it I
can see the course I can add it to the
playlist which I can do why didn't I do
that I add it to the playlist and it
sort of gives me some information and
and it allows me to update whether I've
read it or not and I can also go to the
previous if I want so that's just
something I wanted to mention you also
have a little Settings button there so
that you can decide whether you want the
links to go automatic not automatically
you can change your font size and this
kind of thing ok so we go back to the
text so normally what I would do is I
would go through
this reading and listening now I get a
lot of criticism for the text-to-speech
that it's not very good and I recognize
that text-to-speech is not perfect but
here again in terms of fuzzy logic I
think we have to be tolerant of things
that are less than perfect tolerant of
Google Translate giving us Iran or even
a dictionary gives us the wrong hint the
wrong definition some people complain
that so those accent you know in every
language that I've learned it seems
somebody gets on and says all your
teacher has a bad accident or this is
bad it doesn't matter because you're not
nailing anything down at any stage and
that includes with the with the
text-to-speech no right now it says that
there are 71 if I click it says links 71
at the top right hand corner I could go
through my flashcards before doing it
but I tend not to do that so I just say
that is an option some people like to do
that and of course I can set you know
how many at a time cards precession 26 I
don't like to do ten I don't like to do
100 but 25 or 26 or so is okay sometimes
I do go through them ahead of time
sometimes I go through them you know
when I go from page to page again fuzzy
logic I don't have a set routine I like
is learning to me it's acquired through
exposure so the fact that I'm struggling
with these texts doesn't bother me
because I know that even in struggling
with them I mean being exposed it's
gradually settling in if I go back to
the beginning lessons and I see words
there that I had long ago marked is
known and now no longer remember but
doesn't matter to me every every act of
exposure to the language and listening
and reading is helping the little
sediments are settling in my brain in
some fuzzy way that I can't really
control but so what I would do here is I
would say so
Adar so as sabbia a some bow okay now I
might
pardon my poor Arabic okay so I don't
haven't seen them before but yaha or
something no the fact that all these are
in yellow means there are no more blue
words that means that some where some
time long ago I did this lesson and I
would imagine that most of the yellow
words here I don't know even though I
looked them up and possibly some of the
white words I don't know again you know
the whole process of learning is not one
of cementing in building blocks it's
it's exposure so can I always get a
little more nervous when I do this in
front of other people and that's another
thing the more pressure we feel like
Here I am talking to a group of people
reading through my text the more
pressure we feel the more poorly we do
so that's another consideration so math
alum oh but alum assemble or whatever
there is a metallus learner so there's
elements of that that fine that's it now
I'm not sure you're gonna pick up the
sound I don't know how this works here I
don't think that we will hear the sound
no sound there's no sound that's fine so
I would simply go through and taffeta
elect
Luva arabiya
so opens for you Laura a lobby arabiya
arabic-language
Bob alum doors to a world soccer soccer
is Jezza I'm not sure what that means
I would have to look it up
enchanting attractive okay so these are
words obviously that are fairly along
far along relatively infrequent words I
have no hope of remembering them but I
had the sense that they will show up
eventually if they show up often enough
they'll stick I don't really worry about
it again if you have any questions here
just let me know I just want to share
with you how I go about you know
learning using my iPad and I think it's
the first time I've actually showed the
iPad one thing I sometimes do when
listening to it
we're not hear it but this one times I
can go slower if I want seventy five
point seven five I can go to 0.5 which I
saw that do with a very difficult text
on the other hand if I'm going through
something that's very easy and very slow
and in SC mill in the early lessons they
go very slowly I take it up to two times
or 1.5 times because it's too slow for
me and it gets me through the lesson
faster so these are some of the options
that are available you know in terms of
dictionaries I personally like contacts
traversal I find that it's very very
good and as a dictionary attractive
charming charming attractive okay so
cancel that seems to be the correct
translation there you're just trying to
think of other things that I do oh yeah
I also alternate between sentence view
and page you sentence view of course has
the advantage that you can see each
sentence translated so if I find the
text very difficult I'll go through it
all in sans view and also if you're in
sentence view then the advantage is that
when you are doing your review exercises
they are limited to the few new words
that were on the page so enchanting we
just had that
and open like some coffee or something I
can't remember okay
tuft I got I can't hear it so I not too
clearly how that gets pronounced doesn't
bother II shadaab is this another
charming attractive okay
and I don't change the status yeah
because it's my first issue review it's
just exposure so this is Bob column
doors to the world to the world of doors
of the world okay bingo now that takes
me out onto the next page and again I
get the translation for that line and
there are no yellow words here so there
are no words to review yeah basically
that's kind of a sense of one thing I
also wanted to show you if I go to my
lessons so one of the things that's
really great is I have all the material
call it books that I have brought in you
know different like conversation reports
with my tutors you know al Jazeera
podcast the mini stories and I can go in
any of them and go anywhere beginning
middle end and start reviewing which is
a lot more difficult to do in a book the
books are full of a lot of explanations
and a lot of clutter in my opinion
whereas here I can go in to say that
harab staying going to a lesson I've got
the audio I've got the words the meaning
of the words I can listen to it I can
review it and so I have the sense that
I'm I'm sort of flying over that's
bird's-eye view of all kinds of content
some of which I have worked hard to
bring in here like sort of the
transcribing of the podcast by the way I
should report that the the automatic
transcription company that I was
connecting with and we had problems
getting our I couldn't upload the mp3
file when recognized
they say claim now that they fixed the
problem so theoretically for $30 a month
I can have five hours of automat of
transcription of Arabic podcasts
considering that the average podcast
from Falls badcat has like 12 minutes or
if Al Jazeera's like 20 minutes so in an
hour I've got let's say on average for
podcasts so that's 20 podcasts five
hours of podcasts transcribed that's
more than I can handle so I'm gonna have
some more experience with this and if
other people are interested I can let
them know that the name of the website
but considering the tremendous amount of
podcast stuff that is out there in
Italian Spanish French Chinese Russian
if we can get this automatically
transcribed that gives us a tremendous
amount of learning material so that I
think all I wanted to share with you is
sort of a sort of fuzzy logic approach
that I take to language learning and so
now I'm going to go back to a stop
screen sharing and let's see here
take off my reading glasses put on my
computer glasses and let me know if
there are any questions I'd be happy to
answer any questions
let's see although there are there any
let's have a look here okay here are the
questions when will you learn Turkish I
can't you know I can't wait to start in
the Turkish my wife is watching and I
sneak in there just to look at of it
this amazingly dramatic soap opera
I called burned cocoon in Turkish and
there's just so many twists and turns in
the thing and if I could if I could
understand the Turkish that would be a
lot of fun so I want to do Turkish but
it's not going to be it probably will be
next year because this year I want to
focus on Arabic and Persian
and then because I'm going to the
language of the the polygon conference
in Fukuoka I just want to get give
Korean one more crack so tonight we have
a better handle on Korea and so our
Turkish might be the end of this year
might be beginning of next year okay
that's the process is their friend is
out in Bosnia I mean but African males a
little the English career boomers TV
Dallas exist okay so the question is how
can you use input based learning in a
classroom
ah I'm going to answer in English
because I'm sure this Matteo's de
Santana Rodriguez is a teacher of
English so he understands but I
appreciate getting the questions in
whatever language okay let's look at
some examples there is a thing I have
been to some seminars where they talk
about TP RS teaching proficiency through
reading and storytelling and there the
teacher tells a story in the classroom
tells a story which and there seem to be
two processes one is where the teacher
kind of acts out the story and writes
little stuff on on the whiteboard
drawings and stuff like that so that
they're imparting the meaning so that
even though the students may not know
those words they can understand the
story so they are getting a story and
the goal there is to incentive it to
motivate the learner to go out and read
so the other form of the TRS is where
the students actually contribute to the
story and so the person says that there
was you know a boy who lived in the
forest and then and then the student
will say he went to pick mushrooms or
something and they go around and add to
the story so these are some of the input
based teaching activities that I have
seen referenced and I think if on
Google's CI comprehensible input these
are all identified us see I type
teaching techniques those are out there
if it were me I have no problem with
stood
is actually sitting in the classroom and
reading and you know if they can develop
the habit of reading and maybe ask
questions
which reminds me reading with the help
of a teacher is a good thing especially
if the students have difficulty reading
for example I have difficulty reading
Arabic so the last two sessions with my
tutor I have been reading and she has
been helping me with my reading and
since some of the Arabic for example is
supposed to be Standard Arabic there are
words in there from the Levantine you
know from a certified Palestinian this
was an interview with a Palestinian man
who was planning to run for mayor of
Jerusalem and so he used words that were
not Standard Arabic and she was able to
explain that to me and she was also able
to help me with aspects of the language
that were still fuzzy for me so reading
with people in the class might be
something that could be done I would do
it perhaps individually let people read
and then people can call me over and
help them with their reading for example
if they all read the same story then you
can read for 15 minutes and then spend
some time discussing the story for
example again me and I always refer back
to Rubin Alvez who is a great Brazilian
educator and manat to ask people ask the
learners you know questions to prove
that they understood the story not those
kinds of things but rather discussions
about what they thought of the story
anything having to do with the story but
not necessarily asking them to analyze
or anything of that nature so I would do
some of that and if there was some way
that I could induce them to you know
obviously assigning reading I mean in an
ideal world they would have linked they
would have an iPad they would go away
they come back they would have we would
the teacher would know how much activity
they were involved with what's words
they had saved those words could be used
for a discussion in the classroom so
those are some of the ways that I would
use it but I would incur
Matteo's to Google CI and see you know
the kinds of techniques that are used
and if you wanted to do a trial with us
with Lync we're very happy to set up a
classroom based you know trial where
just for your group and we would isolate
the group and once you have a group
there are so many things you can do for
the group in terms of giving them
content which might otherwise not be
available free of copyright and tracking
your activities and so forth so okay
James Cook what tips can you give for
teaching rather than learning it's it's
kind of a similar a similar question so
again I have to admit I have not been a
classroom teacher I have taught online
we have groups that have used link so
obviously my language learning all of my
language learning activity is based on
link that all the language learning I've
done over the last ten years is based on
thanks so that's my experience it's
obviously not the only way to learn a
language so but if I'm going to talk to
you about my experience I will base it
on link but I think the goal of a
language learner of a language teacher
today my view is that it's
overwhelmingly one of a motivator a
guide stimulator encouraged or these
kinds of things because the teacher used
to be the sort of origin of all wisdom
about the language that's not necessary
there's lots of sources of information
about the language the key thing is to
make the learner curious motivated so
there again if the student is reading in
class and is struggling with something
then the student will ask a question
that's specific to that problem then
they're curious to know the answer so
that grammatical explanation has a
better chance of sticking than something
that's imposed so my inclination would
be to and to motivate to help them find
content of interest to
create situations where they're curious
about something whether it be about the
language or some aspect of the culture
so to stimulate curiosity and then to
encourage because I mean there's no
question that once a learner feels they
have achieved something once we feel we
have achieved something we feel good
about ourselves and we're more inclined
to do more of the same and so that's why
tests where you get five out of ten
that's very very discouraging so I would
avoid tests
I think tests are unnecessary as I said
you can get either than one time six out
of ten the next time you can do well on
your tests I've mentioned the fact that
in english-speaking Canada good students
to do well in their French and pass the
test and at the end of ten years of
instruction can't speak the language so
the tests are relatively useless and
instead the teacher in my mind should
encourage them to get interested and
motivated and then stay with the task
all right so next question here do I
ever think in another language
not really now if I'm surrounded by
French paper you know French and
Japanese maybe if I'm in that
environment and I might find myself
thinking myself in that language but or
does this mean when I think in another
language when I speak that language if I
speaking the languages that I speak well
I just speak them I have no sense of I
have no sense of you know thinking and
translating is just and and all the
language that I speak to the extent that
I've developed sort of natural almost
reflex things things that I can almost
just turn out in phrases they just come
out and I don't think of translating and
then there are parts where you translate
so in every language it's a mixture
I think of thinking in the language
you're speaking and translating from
English okay fair rate of human rate for
transcriptions I don't know but we used
to have transcription yeah I should tell
students a I would say that the rate
we've been paying for different
languages and that I have paid is like
thirty forty dollars US dollars per
audio hour okay so but I
the I saw the the translation or the
transcription of the sample file that I
uploaded and it was very good so I for
language learning this is not these are
not legal documents for language
learning I don't see the advantage of
paying so much more if I can get five
hours for thirty dollars instead of one
hour for thirty dollars
it serves my purpose where would be
other place to find content for our big
Alec specifically Levantine nearly
everything in order okay
we are there is some Levantine Arabic
content in our library
my current tutor Dahlia who has just
joined link
by the way da Li a and if they're sort
of an underscore Dahlia underscore look
for her and maybe I can encourage her to
record some more stuff in Levantine most
a sort of radio and that kind of stuff
is going to be in standard Arabic but I
know that there are TV programs and
other things in eleventeen Arabic so I
think it's just a matter of following up
with mmm following up with people who
are in a position to help us with
resources I mean our Arabic library has
grown and we can add more eleventeen
it's also a matter of demand so you ask
for you know we'll find ways to get it
and you can also look at some of our
members who are from you know Palestine
Jordan Lebanon Syria and you know if
there's a big interest in it I mean we
should try and build it up
does Steve think that the evolution of
AI will stop people from learning
languages because the next 10 years said
the translation will be extremely go ok
now the point is we don't we don't just
learn languages to translate we learn
languages to connect with people and you
know I love the idea that I can hear
this other language and I can get into
the world
that language in the culture in the
history in the language so I don't think
and I've always been able to buy an
English book on Ukrainian history or
Russian history or a Chinese history I
don't want a Ukrainian or China an
English book on those histories I want
to do it in fact one of my major
motivations in learning Russian was that
I wanted to be able to read Russian
novels in the original and so and it's
also a matter of connecting with people
personally you do it in their language
and so the answer to that is I am NOT an
expert on AI but I don't think that
it'll be a major I think if anything the
same things that are leading to a I are
making language learning easier and
easier
oh if I look back ten years ago if I
look back at the evolution of the
technology the iPhone iPad of the ease
with which we toss mp3 files around the
way Google Translate has dramatically
improved the quality of its translations
the quality Texas features improved I
think a lot of these things are also
gonna make language learning easier how
do you have problems with confusing two
languages how to deal with this
sometimes the bigger problem is this is
in learning two languages at the same
time but no the biggest problem is that
I don't have as much time to devote to
one language there are I don't know a
surprising number of Arabic words in
Persian and if anything it helps when I
come across them I sometimes question
myself you know like you know similar
word like need is less am laws than
different pronunciation in Arabic and
farsi persian
is less important than the fact that i
just have less time to spend on language
okay steve Jacquet Anessa Chesky protein
DDG Chesky zirconia Stefania Dickey yeah
[Music]
yessum sailu chief Chesky you know I
answer in English because my Chesky is
not so good but I spent about eight
months to a year actually doing a lot of
listening and reading in Czech
went to Prague for seven six seven days
spoke a lot of Czech when I was there
haven't really spoken it says but I I
follow different Czech journalists on
Twitter I can read and understand what
they write check is one of those
languages that I would just simply have
to warm up a little bit and if I were
you know Chuck speaking environment for
an hour I think I would be right back or
close to where I was
if I were there for a day I would be
further ahead than I ever was so it's
one of these questions that relates to
how do we maintain languages well you
know my top 10 or so languages I don't
really have a problem but the bottom 10
would require a bit of warming up in
order to bring it back to where it was
okay I'm into Norwegian what about
Norwegian library are you gonna try any
of the Scandinavian languages okay we I
think we had a Danish we have Swedish
again if there's a strong demand and if
there are people who can help us find
content we can add more if people are
studying those languages I think we have
Norwegian I'm not sure actually to be
honest I would have to look that up but
am I gonna try any other Scandinavian
languages I mean it's tempting to go in
and really nail down Danish or Norwegian
and then say gee I speak two more
languages but I don't have that much
need for that I can kind of read those
languages and if I were ever in a
situation where I needed to whip up you
know a decent level and Danish or
Norwegian it could be done fairly
quickly so at this point my interest in
doing any other scattered in your
language is limited question do you
think classroom would be replaced by the
Internet no the classroom the the the
Internet or sort of independent learning
and it's not just the internet it's it's
books it's
audio material is all these other things
that we can do on our own those are very
very powerful but the overwhelming
majority people study in classrooms
people are used to it a lot of people
need the motivation the guidance the
direction the coercion that comes from
the classroom so I don't see the
classroom being replaced
I do believe however that certainly what
I have learned over the last 10 years
with Lync and using resources on the
Internet I could never have achieved as
much if I had gone to a language school
so for a very motivated learner
I think the classroom is actually a drag
I much prefer the kind of one-on-one
interaction two or three times a week
that we can have by a link i talky one
of those find ourselves a good tutor and
then do a lot of learning on our own I
think that's more effective if we are
motivated I'm just wondering why link
has good jarate but not Hindi okay it
all depends on what you know we had
someone very motivated to provide us
with Gujarati content if we find someone
who volunteered to provide us with
content for Indians Swahili will put
them up
we simply can't afford to go out there
and try and pay for and generate lots of
content and every you know it's not
every conceivable language these are two
major languages but it's a matter of a
demand and B availability of resources
in those languages okay but that I'm
gonna cut it off and thank you very much
for listening I hope I oh I forgot this
Japanese eat some more it's more orange
they must not be alone each week this
guy Steve Sanner to be known off with
yoga none this guy okay so sorry I
missed that in Japanese so what is my
next goal after Arabic so as I said I'm
doing Arabic and Persian
so the next one probably will be Turkish
because it's kind of connected
geographically culturally so I do I go
to
you don't know put the last name hey
shel or no after come on
torgul Oh being yourself okay thank you
very much bye for now